Salut !
Vous l'avez compris
aujourd'hui on va tourner
la suite extrêmement
demandée de cette vidéo là.
Sur des expériences psychologiques
qui ont été faites sur le cerveau.
Tout ça dans le but
de mieux le comprendre
et vous allez voir que parfois
les conclusions sont surprenantes.
Loïc, jeune entrepreneur,
générique !
[Musique]
C'est la deuxième vidéo
de cette série.
Et il y a encore
de la matière, beaucoup.
Vu vos réactions et vos commentaires
la dernière fois,
on verra pour faire un épisode 3.
ça dépendra de vos réactions
là dans cette vidéo.
Des likes, des commentaires
et du nombre de vues.
En tout cas, abonnez-vous
pour pas rater ensuite l'épisode 3.
Nous allons commencer par parler
des singes de Harry Harlow.
Les singes de Harlow.
On appelle cette expérience
comme ça.
Alors attention, Harlow a vécu
de 1905 à 1981.
Donc autre époque, autre rapport
à ce qui est déontologiquement
bien ou mal.
Son but était de comprendre
et d'étudier la formation
qui liait un enfant,
un bébé avec sa mère.
Que ce soit du point de vue
de la dépendance affective
ou la dépendance à la nourriture
que lui fournit sa mère.
A cette époque,
les psychanalystes pensaient
qu'un enfant s'attachait à sa mère
via son besoin de nourriture
et comme elle compensait ce besoin,
comme elle offrait la nourriture.
Eh ben forcément ça crée
l'affection à ce moment là.
Lui il voulait voir si
c'était vraiment ça le délire.
Donc il a pris des
bébés singes, des Rhésus
et il les a séparés de leurs mères
pour les élever dans des cages.
Et c'est là où je dis
que c'est moralement
hyper contestable évidemment.
Une fois le bébé dans la cage, il avait
le choix entre deux mères possibles.
Des fausses mères qui avaient
été placées dans la cage.
Une qui était faite
entièrement en fil de fer
et qui avait un biberon, avec du lin
à l'intérieur qui était accroché à elle.
Et que le bébé pouvait
prendre pour se nourrir.
Et une autre qui était en tissu.
La première chose significative,
c'est que les bébés
contrairement du coup,
à ce qu'on pensait
par rapport au fait
qu'il y ait une mère
qui a la nourriture et l'autre pas.
Ont passé la majorité de leur temps
près de la mère en tissu.
Donc à la recherche
de confort et d'affection.
Il est allé plus loin dans l'expérience
en plaçant les bébés dans une cage
où il y avait qu'une seule
des deux mères.
Et pour faire des comparatifs.
Donc un coup c'était un bébé
avec la mère en fer et le lait d'accroché.
Et un coup c'était un bébé avec la mère
en tissu et pas de nourriture accroché.
Eh bien ceux qui étaient
avec la fausse mère en tissu
avaient plus tendance
à avoir confiance en eux.
Et comment on le sait ?
C'est parce que
ils exploraient le territoire,
ils allaient chercher,
ils revenaient, etc.
Alors que les autres
restaient accrochés derrière
ou près de la mère en fer.
Mais n'osaient surtout pas aller
plus loin à droite et à gauche.
Le deuxième comportement
qui a été observé,
c'est que lorsqu'il y avait
quelque chose qui faisait peur.
Par exemple il faisait
un bruit très effrayant,
il faisait tomber
quelque chose, etc.
Les bébés singes avec la mère
en tissu couraient près d'elle
et se blottissaient contre elle.
Les bébés singes qui étaient
avec la mère en fer
et qui avaient le biberon rempli de lait,
eux se recroquevillaient
ou tournaient dans la cage
après sans but, très effrayés.
Ils avaient pas de point de repère.
Donc on sait qu'à partir
de ce moment là,
que les bébés singes vont vraiment
se blottir contre leur mère.
Pas pour un besoin de nourriture,
mais par un vrai besoin d'affection.
Besoin d'affection mais aussi
besoin de contact,
besoin de chaleur, besoin de
serrer quelqu'un contre soi.
Si c'est vrai pour les bébés singes,
on sait que c'est probablement vrai
aussi pour les bébés humains.
Ce qui est fou quand même
c'est que Harlow,
à l'époque c'était
complètement à contre-courant,
d'aller contre les psychanalystes
et les behavioristes.
Qui eux pensaient que cet attachement
qu'avait un bébé avec sa mère
était forcément lié
au deal de la nourriture.
Elle me nourrit donc je vais l'aimer.
On pensait vraiment ça à l'époque.
Et donc lui s'en est pris
clairement plein les dents
pour être monté au créneau
et avoir dit le contraire.
Nous allons parler de
l'épuisement de l'ego
et du biais de contrainte
de Baumeister.
En gros il s'était dit :
La volonté, si ça se trouve
c'est un petit peu
comme une bouteille d'eau
qui contiendrait de l'eau.
Et l'eau serait cette volonté.
C'est à dire qu'il y en a un stock,
assez déterminé pour une journée.
Et c'est pas à l'infini.
Voici l'étude qu'il a mis en place.
Il a mis des participants,
des volontaires dans une pièce
où il y avait de magnifiques
gâteaux fort appétissants.
Il faut savoir que les participants
n'avaient pas encore mangé.
Et des radis.
Juste des radis.
Il y a pas de beurre, pas de sel,
il y a rien, okay.
Et il a dit :
"Vous devez résister,
vous devez pas manger les gâteaux,
vous devez manger les radis.
C'est tout ce que vous avez le droit,
vraiment vous n'avez pas
le droit de manger des gâteaux".
Il y a un autre groupe qu'a eu
le droit de faire ça également.
Mais eux ils avaient le droit
de manger ce qu'ils voulaient.
Des gâteaux, les radis,
ce qu'ils voulaient.
Ces deux groupes individuellement ont
ensuite été mis dans une autre pièce
où ils devaient résoudre
un puzzle très compliqué.
Ce qui a été montré,
de manière significative
c'est que ceux qui avaient
résisté aux gâteaux,
ont abandonné le puzzle plus tôt.
Parce qu'il était
quasiment infaisable.
Et donc ils ont lâché beaucoup plus tôt
que ceux qui avaient eu le droit
de manger des gâteaux
plutôt que les radis.
Parce que quoi qu'il arrive
ils se seraient quand même nourris,
avec les radis il y avait
une quantité suffisante.
Donc ce n'était pas
la notion de faim.
C'était ou tu mangeais
des gâteaux ou des radis.
Baumeister a appelé ça
l'épuisement de l'égo.
Loran Nordgren a appelé ça
le biais de contrainte.
En gros pour Loran Nordgren,
on a un état froid et un état chaud.
L'état froid, c'est admettons :
J'ai déjà mangé et je me retrouve
face à quelque chose
de très appétissant que
j'ai pas le droit de manger.
ça me pose pas de problème
mais je vais sous-estimer l'attrait
qu'il aurait pu avoir envers moi
si j'avais eu faim.
Donc je ne vais pas me protéger
pour la prochaine fois
où j'aurais à faire à cette situation.
Ce qui fait que si je suis
dans un état chaud.
C'est à dire, là j'ai faim et la chose
sur laquelle je dois avoir de la volonté,
c'est quelque chose à laquelle
il m'est dur de résister vu mon état.
Eh bien je vais céder parce que
j'ai pas assez appréhendé au préalable
la résistance qu'il fallait avoir
par rapport à ça.
Parce que aujourd'hui, c'est ça
quand même qui est bien.
On a des preuves qu'on peut
travailler notre volonté
et l'acquérir et un petit peu,
la muscler en fait.
Qu'elle soit de plus en plus efficace.
En gros si vous résistez à
quelque chose aujourd'hui et demain.
Peut-être que ce sera de plus en plus
simple de résister à cette chose là.
Alors là, c'est peut-être
ma préférée de la vidéo.
C'est une bombe atomique
qu'a posée en 1970,
David Rosenhan dans
le milieu psychiatrique.
A cette époque
pour lui, il se dit
que tout ce qui a attrait aux maladies
mentales et à la psychiatrie,
est trop lié à l'interprétation
individuelle et subjectif des médecins.
En gros, on ne s'y connaît pas assez,
il n'y a pas assez d'éléments factuels
qui permettent de déterminer
que telle personne est atteinte
de telle maladie mentale ou pas.
Il en est tellement persuadé
qu'il lance une étude dans son coin.
Il envoie huit personnes
à lui aux urgences.
Et ces personnes là déclarent qu'elles
ont des hallucinations auditives.
Okay, donc ça elles le disent,
elles l'expliquent.
Et du coup les huit se font interner
dans un hôpital psychiatrique.
Sauf que à partir du moment
où elles ont mis un pied
dans l'hôpital de psychiatrique,
elles ont tout refait normalement.
Elles ont parlé normalement,
elles ont plus jamais dit
qu'elles avaient de nouveau
des hallucinations auditives
ou des choses comme ça.
Bref, elles ont repris leur
comportement de tous les jours.
Ce qu'il faut savoir,
c'est que dès que ces huit personnes
sont arrivées aux urgences.
Elles ont été diagnostiquées
comme étant schizophrènes.
Et c'est ça qui les a conduits
à l'internement.
Mais comme durant l'internement
il n'y avait plus aucun signal
de leur schizophrénie.
Ils ont interprété
l'absence de symptômes
comme faisant partie
intégrante de leur maladie.
Maladie qui, je le rappelle
n'existe pas du tout.
C'était même pas simulé,
ça a été juste une déclaration
une seule fois aux urgences.
Rosenhan a révélé le pot-aux-roses
que tout ça c'était pour une étude
qu'il avait mis en place, etc.
Et même l'hôpital en question
et d'autres hôpitaux
se sont montrés
hyper sceptiques en disant :
"Mouais faut voir.
On n'est pas sûr que ce soit vrai,
puis ça se trouve au fond d'eux
ils étaient schizophrènes".
Et la où c'est un génie ce gars.
Rosenhan laisse courir la rumeur,
qu'il va lancer d'autres tests
de toute manière
pour confirmer toute son étude.
Donc il laisse se répandre
cette nouvelle là
dans tous les hôpitaux psychiatriques
et dans tous les centres d'internement.
Sauf qu'il n'envoie personne.
A part les huit premiers, il envoie
plus personne à compter de ce jour.
A partir du moment où
il a annoncé cette nouvelle,
que l'étude allait continuer,
qu'il allait envoyer d'autres personnes.
L'hôpital en question dans lequel
il avait envoyé les huit premiers.
Ont déterminé qu'il y a
48 personnes qui faisaient semblant
et 23 qui étaient suspects et qui,
si ça se trouve faisaient semblant.
alors que là pour le coup,
il avait envoyé personne.
Grâce à lui ça a amélioré
la rigueur dont faisait preuve
ensuite les médecins pour faire
les diagnostics psychiatriques.
Sachant en même temps qu'il y avait
cette question déontologique de :
Est-ce que c'est bien de notre faute
de poser un mauvais diagnostic,
si on nous fait un témoignage
de mauvais symptômes,
si on nous ment en clair.
Est-ce que c'était à eux
de déterminer que les gens étaient...
Que les personnes étaient des
personnes qui mentaient ou pas.
En tout cas ça a complètement
révolutionné et troublé
et fait avancer en fait dans un sens,
le milieu psychiatrique.
L'utilité attendue ou
la théorie des perspectives
de Kahneman et Tversky.
L'utilité attendue, c'est la manière
la plus logique, la plus raisonnée,
la plus rationnelle d'évaluer
un risque en fait.
On va faire un exemple concret.
C'est un exemple que
vous allez perdre de l'argent,
quoi qu'il arrive vous allez
perdre de l'argent.
Soit vous avez d'un côté
un choix à faire
où vous avez 100% de chances
de perdre 15 euros.
Soit de l'autre côté
vous avez un autre choix où
vous avez que 5 % de chances
de perdre 400 euros.
Donc vous êtes obligés de faire
l'un de ces deux choix.
Assez, on va dire intuitivement
et émotionnellement.
On ferait le choix de se dire :
"Ben je prends le 5 % de chances
de perdre 400 euros".
Plutôt que d'être sûr
de perdre de l'argent.
C'est ce qui paraît,
on a envie de le tenter.
Dans la réalité, dans le rationnel
si on fait le calcul de l'utilité attendue.
On va faire un fois 15.
un pour 100% fois 15.
Donc ça nous fait 15.
On va le comparer
avec l'autre chiffre.
Donc c'était 5% de 400 euros.
Donc 5% ça fait 0,05.
Donc on va faire 0,05
multiplié par 400.
Et le bon choix à faire,
c'est le résultat le plus bas.
Donc on a tout intérêt
à être certain de perdre 15 euros,
plutôt que de tenter notre chance
à en perdre 400.
La théorie des perspectives
de Kahneman et Tversky.
Elle nous démontre
que on évalue différemment
nos chances de gagner
quelque chose
versus nos chances
de perdre quelque chose.
C'est pas les mêmes biais,
c'est pas les mêmes émotions.
Et du coup ça fait pas
la même intuition
et on n'a pas la même
rationalité des deux côtés,
suivant qu'on évalue
une chance de gain potentiel
ou une une chance
de perte potentielle.
Ils ont démontré qu'on a
ce réflexe là,
d'être prêt à miser
sur une grosse perte potentielle.
Plutôt que sur une petite
perte sûre à 100%.
Imaginez vous êtes en train
de marcher dans la rue.
Et puis là il y a quelque chose
qui brille dans votre œil,
c'est un peu gênant
et vous regardez.
Il y a quelque chose de caché
sous une feuille par terre.
Vous avez soulevé la feuille
et là vous trouvez un diamant.
Un vrai beau gros diamant,
avec en plus
comme par hasard à côté,
un certificat d'authenticité.
et là vous avez une joie immense
qui rentre en vous.
Et vous vous mettez à sourire.
Eh bien apparemment
ça ne se passe pas comme ça.
C'est même plutôt l'inverse
et ça c'est la théorie
de James-Lange.
Pour James et Lange,
c'est un stimulus qui va provoquer
une réaction physiologique.
En l'occurrence, le fait de sourire.
Et c'est le fait de sourire
qui va provoquer ensuite la joie.
Et c'est non pas la joie
qui provoque le sourire.
Pour étayer son propos,
James avait un contre-exemple.
Il disait que si vous rencontrez
un ours féroce, un moment donné.
Et que vous partez en courant.
En fait c'est parce que
vos jambes tremblent,
que vous avez de l'adrénaline
dans le sang
et que vous êtes en train de fuir.
Que vous ressentez
l'émotion de la peur.
C'est ça la théorie
de l'émotion en fait.
C'est tous ces facteurs physiologiques
qui font que vous ressentez de la peur
à l'issue de
ces facteurs physiologiques.
Début du 20ème siècle,
le physiologiste Walter Cannon
a voulu démontrer
que cette théorie de l'émotion
était complètement fausse.
Et donc il a fait,
bon un truc horrible.
Il a empêché via la moelle épinière
de certains chiens,
d'avoir un feedback physiologique,
pour voir si ces chiens-là
ressentaient encore des émotions.
Ils ressentaient encore
des émotions.
Et il y a quelques années,
il y a eu de nouvelles études
qui ont prouvé en réalité que
la théorie des émotions
de James-Langes était vraie.
ça veut dire que quand
on se force à sourire
on va changer un peu
notre état d'esprit, notre mindset
pour quelque chose de plus positif.
Puisqu'il est habitué à ça.
Et c'est vrai d'ailleurs, on avait fait
une vidéo à l'époque
avec Céline H sur ma chaîne.
Où elle m'apprenait à faire
des émotions, etc.
Et elle dans son jeu
de comédienne,
quand elle déclenche
tous les signaux de la tristesse
et toute l'expression de la tristesse,
alors elle l'arrivait
plus facilement à pleurer.
Et les études récentes
ont montré aussi également
que les personnes
qui avaient trop de botox
ou du botox depuis
trop longtemps,
Ou qui s'en réinjectaient
trop souvent du moins.
Parce que ça reste
pas éternellement.
Elles avaient moins de feedback.
Et du coup elles avaient
des émotions
qui étaient un peu étouffées,
un peu amoindries.
On va terminer avec
les stades moraux de Kohlberg
qui est quelque chose qui nous
concerne tous depuis notre enfance
et qui nous concerne
encore aujourd'hui.
Pour vous mettre juste
aussi dans le contexte,
parce que parfois
c'est quand même intéressant.
Il faut savoir que Lawrence Kohlberg
a vécu de 1927 à 1987.
Il a étudié le comportement
des enfants
et plus précisément
le comportement moral
pour essayer de voir
s'il y avait un stéréotype
et de faire une sorte
de classement de stades
dans les comportements moraux.
En gros il leur présentait
des dilemmes moraux.
Et il étudiait, il étayait
leurs réponses.
Pour Kohlberg, il y a trois niveaux
de développement moral.
Et ces trois niveaux sont eux mêmes
subdivisés en deux sous-niveaux.
Le stade 1, qui est le premier stade
qu'on vit durant notre enfance.
Selon lui, c'est le stade moral
où on détermine
ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal,
en fonction de ce qui est puni ou pas,
tout simplement.
On a pas de jugement là dessus.
Le stade 2, c'est celui où
on détermine ce qui est bien et mal
en fonction de
ce que les autres veulent
et de est-ce qu'ils nous
rapportent une récompense.
Le stade 3, c'est en fonction
de ce qui plaît aux autres.
Au sens du bien et du mal,
le bon comportement.
Et en fonction de ce qui les aide.
Le stade 4, c'est le respect
de l'autorité.
Le stade 5, donc là
on passe au troisième niveau.
Et ça veut pas dire que
tout le monde atteindra ce stade
d'ailleurs dans sa vie,
c'est pas obligé.
C'est le moment où
les enfants comprennent
que le droit individuel
de la personne,
peut passer au dessus
du droit de l'autorité.
Donc en gros, qu'il y a
un droit moral individuel
qui peut passer
au dessus des règles.
Un exemple très dur et très concret,
mais malgré l'autorité parentale,
si un parent est violent
avec son enfant,
eh bien l'enfant va comprendre
en fait que c'est pas normal.
Et qu'il peut par exemple
aller le dénoncer
ou aller chercher
de l'aide ailleurs.
Parce que cette règle
est injuste en fait.
Je caricature de ouf.
Et le stade 6, c'est le plus élevé.
C'est notre comportement
vis-à-vis du bien et du mal.
Qui sont déterminés après par notre
propre éthique et nos propres valeurs.
D'égalité, d'entraide,
de fraternité de...
C'est notre justice personnelle
que l'on a construite après
au fil des années,
au fil de nos expériences
et au fil de nos jugements.
Kohlberg pensait que
seulement 10 % des adultes
atteignent ce stade moral là.
C'est pas quelque chose
de généralisé pour lui.
Et après plus tard
il aura même jusqu'à été dire
que si ça se trouve,  le stade 6
c'est pas forcément un stade distinct,
que c'est un peu autre chose.
Alors comme toutes
les études et les théories,
celle-ci est controversée.
Même celles d'avant,
il y a toujours des contradicteurs.
Et après il y a plus ou moins de preuves
comme quoi c'est controversé
et si ça se trouve,
il y en aura un peu plus tard.
C'est jamais vraiment figé dans
le temps ce genre de choses.
Alors qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de tout ça ?
Parce qu'encore une fois certaines
études sont controversées aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est quand même
intéressant de les connaître,
parce que ça nous montre
aussi à l'époque
comment on appréhendait le cerveau.
Et encore une fois dans 20 ans
ou dans 30 ans, on se dira :
"Ah mais c'est marrant
ils pensaient ça en 2020
alors que vraiment c'est
complètement obsolète aujourd'hui".
D'ailleurs je vous raconterai
quelques fun facts sur ce sujet là,
aujourd'hui sur mon Instagram
qui doit s'afficher ici
quelque part autour de moi.
Tous les jours
je fais des fun facts
sur des sujets assez
intéressants comme ça.
Et vous pouvez aussi me voir
dire des trucs intéressants,
tout en étant drôle,
tout en vous bluffant
et tout en vous amenant
à vous bluffer vous-même,
dans mon spectacle sur scène
qui s'appelle 'Singularité'.
En gros c'est un spectacle
de mentalisme,
où quand vous sortez de la salle
vous vous dites :
"Mais je savais pas
qu'il était drôle ce mec
et que moi aussi je pouvais
être moi-même mentaliste
et que je savais faire
ce que je viens de faire".
Bref, la tournée de ce spectacle
est dans la description.
C'est la dernière tournée
pour ce spectacle
qu'on a décalé avec tout ce qui
se passait durant le confinement.
C'est à dire que après
le mois de mai 2021,
je ne jouerai plus jamais
ce spectacle.
Venez, prenez votre place
au Zénith de Paris,
la date elle va être ouf
le 20 novembre 2020.
Il y a des surprises,
y a des invités juste incroyables.
Là à l'image que vous voyez apparaître,
c'est les places qui restent.
En gros tout ce qui est noir
est déjà pris,
donc vous pouvez
prendre votre place.
Je crois que c'est
à partir de 29 euros.
Le lien est dans la bio.
Si vous ne me connaissiez pas,
je m'appelle Fabien Olicard,
vous pouvez vous abonner
à cette chaîne YouTube.
Allez-y c'est gratuit, pour ne pas
rater la prochaine vidéo.
Je vous conseille chaudement
d'activer la cloche.
Likez la vidéo si elle vous a plu,
vous avez vu deux vidéos apparaître.
ça c'est la première vidéo
de cette série,
qu'on vient de tourner.
Donc sur les expériences
sur le cerveau en psychologie.
Et ça c'est une vidéo sur,
si les extraterrestres existent
comment ça se fait qu'ils sont
pas aujourd'hui parmi nous ?
Vous avez les réponses
dans cette vidéo.
A très bientôt,
Ciao !